some big changes in our economy are
giving american workers more options
than they've had in decades and millions
of americans are giving up jobs to chase
new opportunities the labor department
says there were 11 million job openings
in the month of october that is close to
an all-time record another 4.2 million
americans quit their jobs voluntarily in
october mark strossman now shows us how
the numbers are hitting home in many
different ways
these strikers in omaha have had it like
millions of american workers they're
among 1400 employees who walked out of
kellogg's cereal plants nine weeks ago
and this week most voted to reject the
company's latest offer i feel we have
the upper hand right now picketers used
words like leverage to explain their
first strike in almost a half century
there just isn't enough skilled
craftsmen to fill all these openings
you're not that easy to replace no
few employees are these days job
openings nationwide above 10 million for
five straight months wrapped inside the
great resignation new opportunities you
see fast food companies offering signing
bonuses
you see professional services and tech
companies offering
benefits even over the robust benefits
that are already available
consider construction jobs at a time
when home sales and prices are both
booming
they're running the wire through
through the house in idaho developer
joatalus building this house outside
boise the good news is these guys are
showing up
yeah these guys are on the job
exactly because that's not true for
everybody
it's not
metro boise has too few homes for sale
and too few workers to build more in one
year local home prices jumped 30 percent
the industry's worried about the 430 000
unfilled construction jobs right now and
in three years that number could
multiply fivefold 2.2 million open jobs
it's tough to predict how long the home
will take because you don't know when
the materials will show up and when the
labor will show up in the kellogg strike
the company says it's done negotiating
it will hire all replacement workers
what comforts these strikers nebraska's
unemployment rate america's lowest
1.9 percent for cbs morning's mark
straussman omaha
so it's another nice piece there from
from mark if you zoom back and look at
the big picture america creates lots of
jobs we've got 11 million of them in
october uh opened but not a lot of them
are what economists call good jobs ones
that put you with a wage you can maybe
buy a home put a little away for
retirement save for college and until
jobs start coming to the table with
offerings like that a lot of workers are
going to say
you think i'm disposable you're
disposable too yeah i hear you're
working on something yes i also went out
talked to some kellogg's employees uh
and for a piece that i think we're going
to air next week taking a look at that
bigger picture because it's not just
about any one company right here these
are bigger changes in the u.s economy
over like a 50-year period looking
forward to that